accorde
si Neptune possède ton désir
alors je le mettrai
de côté
je chevauche un hippocampe dans ton eau
jusqu'à ce que nous entendions brisé dans
la nature
parce qu'il y
a toi dans tout ce qui est
connu
si seulement je
pouvais te voir
ce rêve
ne serait pas
si difficile
si seulement je
pouvais  à bientôt,
ce rêve
serait
aussi très dur ouais
parce que je
sais
que si les étoiles filantes te font réfléchir,
je peindrai le ciel
toute la journée
pour que nous puissions planer et voler ensemble
si seulement je
pouvais te voir,
ce rêve
serait
si dur
si  seulement je
peux te voir,
ce rêve
ne serait pas
si difficile ouais
toi et tout le sais
parce que